you know I see a lot of new
entrepreneurs that are coming up they
are desperately dying for people to
value their time I am so important
please value my time believe me I am
worth so much money
but the market says listen we don't
value your time we don't respect your
time we don't see you as too valuable
yet and that frustrates a lot of people
now watch this I know this because I
went through it this is what typically
happens when you're coming up nobody
values your time then you get to a
tipping point where you start showing
the market that hey I am worth a lot
then all of a sudden want to get to this
tipping point a bunch of people decide
to pull you in all these different
directions family shows up out of
nowhere who never used to call you now
they're calling your friends want to
hang out with you
exes want to hang out with you new
people want to hang out coworkers want
to hang out with you because you're
coming up so what are you doing that
time listen if you're not too careful
during that time all of those people
will make you feel so guilty
that all of a sudden you'll start
wasting your time in areas that are not
gonna help you grow and you'll actually
go backwards today in this video I'm
gonna give you a few different ways of
looking at your time valuing your time
and some things that you've never
thought about they start processing your
time in a completely different way so do
I want to break this video down to use
in three different areas one are we
going to talk about the levels and where
you're at coming up right the second
thing we're going to talk about is you
and who you should give your time to who
you should be protective of and then
last but not least allocating your time
on what project you give time to those
three areas I'll cover with you in the
video I'll recommend to other videos at
the end of it about time management and
we're gonna give you an infographic to
download take a look at and laminate it
put it on your office and your you know
shower
you know wall whatever it is as long as
you can see this thing over and over and
over again eventually these concepts
what bleedin channel be a part of you so
having said that let's get right into it
point number one no matter who you are
you fall under one of these three
different categories you're either
coming up as a new person you could be a
new real estate agent new insurance guy
new digital market a new doctor new
dentist new liquor store new deli but
it's new in your community no one knows
you you're coming up number two is your
name in a market place people know you
if they see your face a name that's a
local real estate agent that's a local
dentist that's a local doctor that's a
local liquor
so that's a deli store down the street
but you're a name you're not the pace
setter yet your name and then there's
the front runner front runners you're
number one in your community in your
state in your country but you are number
one everybody follows your pace whatever
you do they follow your pace you're the
lead dog in your industry in your
community in your city right having said
that a lot of times a person coming up
once the kind of respect of a front
runner or you haven't earned it yet so
you'll hear things that people saying
while I'm busy I'm really busy you'll
hear this word I'm really busy I'm
really busy the word busy has three
different categories in it the first
kind of busy is the facade busy what's
facade busy you're a real estate agent
no one is talking to you you don't have
any clients but no client wants to do
business with a real estate agent that
has a lot of time on their hands so you
have to say what well I'm busy your
bluff in the world
I'm busy I've got so many clients I've
got so many appointments let me see if I
can put you in a two clock that doesn't
work for me I can do three o'clock well
you know what I just had a cancellation
three o'clock so people play this fake
busy tactic that they play which is fine
if you're a newcomer coming up but you
can only do that for so long
eventually the goal is to actually
become busy when you are busy versus a
facade busy everybody feels the
difference they notice the difference
forget about the language of what you
say people feel that you are really busy
then third one is you're extremely busy
what does this mean you used to do an
hour and a half appointment now you're
doing 30 minutes now you can't see doing
this you can't see doing this you can't
see doing this used to be on a phone
call that would be 45 minutes now you're
asking if we can make it 20 minutes used
to normally do an hour appointment now
you're doing 10 minute appointments you
should normally write a very very long
email that's a simpler email because you
are now officially extremely busy used
to have one assistant and now you have
three assistants now you have an
executive system maybe you're hiring a
chief of staff depending on what level
you're at so those are two things to
keep in mind coming up name in the
market place for a front-runner facade
busy busy extremely busy depending on
those two you can't be a facade busy
wanted to get paid of an extremely busy
person you can't be a comment I wanting
to get paid of a front runner because
you haven't earned that right in the
marketplace yet and a marketplace
dictates what you're worth so when you
look at this you today have to take a
moment outside of the video and actually
decide what you are worth in a
marketplace not what you think you're
worth it's like it's kind of like I
think my house is worth a million the
markets is at six hundred thousand
dollars you can say your house is worth
a million no one's buying it this is why
a lot of homes stay in a marketplace for
two years it's been on a market for six
hundred twenty days why because the
owner thinks the house is worth the
price that the market doesn't want to
pay for so you can say you're worth more
but no one's paying for it I think I'm
about four hundred dollars and no one's
paying you as an attorney four hundred
dollars an hour you need to start off at
two hundred dollars an hour again go
back and figure out what you think
you're worth based on market value not
what you would like to be what you
currently are worth then every time you
do a task put an hour next to it this
task takes me three hours I am worth
fifty this is kind of take me three
hours that's $150 is it worth my hundred
fifty dollars you may sit there and say
yes because the long term I'm gonna make
XYZ return on this no problem you may
sit there and say no why do I keep doing
this this is a 10 $15 an hour job I'm
not gonna be doing this then you adjust
to a different place then you also have
to make a determination of what you're
gonna do to get to $100 now $200 now
$500 $1,000 $50,000 an hour a hundred
thousand dollars an hour whatever it is
your marketplace you dictate that but
eventually when you get here the market
says this is what's your words so now
that is you're looking at your time or
what level you're at let me give you the
middle part this is Association this is
you okay you have three types of people
that you need to spend time with one is
people above you who are way ahead of
you let's just say you're making a
million out of your income you spend
time with somebody making 10 million and
there's seven years ahead of you where
you are with your business they're
investing into you you need to be around
them because they pull you up any oh my
gosh why do I think so small I can't
believe only think this big why can I be
thinking look at the sky why this is so
crazy we have so many other things we
can do right on advisor or mentor board
something like that they invest in you
then you have relationships that are at
the same level as you they give you
sanity and they give you a peace of mind
why because you are not the only person
that's struggling with your wife your
kids and
how do I manage all this stuff you are
not the only person that's struggling
with your best personal left you and
become your competitor you are not the
only person that all of a sudden your
boards that were taking money back
you're not the only person that's going
through it and you're hearing other
people at the same level as you how they
handled it then you relax it's okay this
is normal I can Helen and you go on and
make your decision and the last one is
investment this is future this is giving
back this is community this is a way of
you spending time with people that look
up to you oh my gosh I can't believe I'm
spending time with you're like wow I'm
really important I really do bring value
in people's life this is pretty amazing
my life is worthy because other people
want my time all three are necessary
however the goal is eventually for me
today if you call my phone there are 15
names though no matter what meeting I'm
in unless if my phone is off where I'm
shooting a video or I'm sitting with an
interview or I'm doing something that my
phone's not next to me anything else
there are 15 names they call me phone is
picked up first ring it's picked up
what's happening first ring it's picked
up okay there are 50 names not 50 names
not a hundred names and not 200 names my
phone has 27,000 numbers in there but
only 50 names I pick up when they call
me why because the goal is to eventually
get to a few friends many acquaintances
few business partners many associates
few influencers many creators to many
people they're looking at this as a
popularity contest I am NOT trying to
answer the phone to 600 people I'm not
I'm not trying to become you know best
friends with everybody I hope everybody
likes me you will be miserable you will
not get nothing done the goal is to
realize who is worthy of your time and
who's not right so few friends many
acquaintances few business partners many
associates few influencers many creators
not the other way around so 15 is my
rule you can do 50 you can do 100 you
can do 200 I go by the 15 rule that's
what I have so this leads me to the last
thing to be thinking about you'll get a
lot of projects when you're newer coming
up you can't say oh I'm only gonna focus
on this project you can't because you're
the assistant you're the front desk
you're the processor you're this you're
that you're doing so many different
tasks when you're newer Sonor person
may put 10% of their time into 10
different projects and then you
eventually graduate that a little bit
and maybe it's going to be 20% of your
time into five different areas because
now you have staff now you have
supporting cast now you have different
people helping you out the goal is to
eventually get to a point were you
putting in 90% of your time in the
project that has the biggest upside that
needs your attention and 10% into
minutia let me say this one more time
90% of your time into one project okay
90% your time into your main core team
that has the biggest upside 90% into
your next leader that can run the
company that can replace you in many
areas you're 90 percent goes there
you're 10% goes to everybody else when
you get to this point believe it or not
growth is higher we run an insurance
company been around for 10 years okay we
have 9700 agents nationwide we have a
hundred plus offices nationwide right 49
different states this year 2019 we are
growing faster than ever before and my
attention is going to fewer things than
ever before what happened because I'm
putting 90% into the project that has
the highest upside not 20 20 20 20 20
because I can't grow it that way I have
to go fully into the project that gives
me the biggest upside hence we're a
bigger company today and we're grown at
a bigger percentage than ever before
because of the 90/10 run I know a lot of
people say well I don't know about this
that's kind of unfair you know how about
the other person that needs your time on
all this I get it I get it
but I don't feel guilty about it anymore
I used to at one point not anymore today
because the 90% that goes into that
small group wants it more than everybody
else and has the biggest return that's
who gets my time so having said that you
got to process these three for yourself
where are you at with the level you're
currently at where do you want to be put
that goal for yourself and do the math
your second who do you associate
yourself the most with how many friends
do you have you oh are you accessible to
all your acquaintances are you
accessible to all this other stuff and
by the way the other day I had ski I had
a speaker that I hired to speak at one
of our events sales guy we had a
conference called a two o'clock so I got
on the call it's two o'clock the lady
says oh he's running a little bit late
wait a minute I paid you you're running
a little bit late I don't understand
this part I said Nancy is
it's really happening who's the customer
here you are why are we waiting for him
I said ma'am I'm sorry we don't work
that way we have to reschedule this time
but he's about to finish only five more
minutes man we don't have that kind of
time you let him know the next time we
schedule time I need him to be on time
the next conference called we did look
what happened call is set up at two
o'clock do you know I had my staff get
on the call early to see what time he
got on the Colt do you know what time he
got on the call he got on the call at
1:50 do you know what happened in that
moment that influencer realized we value
our time and you better value our time
as well because we respect you we expect
that same thing in return too many times
people let those small things go here
and there
you got a value a time when you're
dealing with other people who don't know
you yet right so again this is you who
do you want to value your time with the
15 calls and last but not least projects
and so this is why I told you there's
two other videos to watch one video I
want you to watch a 16 time wasters so
many people have these sixteen time
wasters this is this one the other thing
I want you to watch is ten times saving
hacks that I produced whichever one
pertains to where you're out right now
watch that one but I highly recommend
you watch both of them and I told you
we're gonna have an infographic if you
text seven four seven two six zero eight
four six one again seven four seven two
six zero eight four six one you will get
the link to an infographic we made for
you to download to print out to put it
on a laminator put in your shower wall
wherever it is so you can see this over
and over and over again so eventually
all of this stuff becomes a part of you
you got any questions or thoughts
comment below and if you haven't
subscribed to the channel please do so
take everybody bye-bye